hey everyone welcome to a new video in
the react.js series today we learn all
about react state I suggest you watch
the previous videos on react components
and props to get a better understanding
of state so let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either by a user
interactions or Network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react three renders the
component to the browser the state is
initialized in the constructor a state
can also store multiple properties a
method called set state is used to
update the value of the state object now
this function performs a shallow march
on the new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow march ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learnt about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props inner components are
used to pass data and even handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the webpage props are
immutable once set by the parent they
cannot be changed State holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state alright so in my
code editor that is vs code I've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder I have my app dot J's file
now here I'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that I'm not going to
be using also I suggest you go to the
react installation on windows video to
help you get started with creating your
first application so let's create our
class component say
app extents react top component inside a
veranda method that returns an HTML tag
let's display a message welcome let's
follow the JSX conventions and enclose
all the HTML tags within the div tag so
I say div class main equals app we also
have to import the app dot CSS file
input app dot CSS so we save it and if
you look at the browser we have welcome
now let's beautify our code to do that
let's add some styling so here in my
after J's class component I say styles
equals and I say font style and I set it
to say bold and I say color say teeth
and here in my h1 tag I say style equals
this dot styles so let me save it and if
you look at the browser now we have
welcome in teal and it's bold
now let's go ahead and create a class
component to understand state so first I
create a folder and I call it components
and inside this folder I create a class
component and I call it new comp dot Jas
and I use the snippet RCE to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we are doing today will
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to simply on once the user
clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we are
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet our Const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's see that
and you are in our render method and say
class main equals
and let's create an h3 tag and within
the tag I displayed the message so I say
this dot state dot message let's save it
and now let's import it in our apt ojs
component so I will get rid of export
here and here I say import neucom from
components and let's define it here and
say you so receive it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to something
on alright again to make our code look
more presentable let's add in styles so
I'll just copy the same styles that I've
added here and I piss them here and
instead of bold and make it italic and I
changed the color to say Kabul and again
in my h3 tag I define style and Misha is
it reduced all styles so let me save it
and now if you look at the browser it's
in italic and it's in purple okay so
moving ahead let's create a button that
reads subscribe and once the user clicks
on it the button should read subscribed
and the message stayed above should
instruct the user to click on the bell
icon to do that let's first create a
button the message that I want the
button to deed is subscribe however this
message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here I
create a prop I say sub and I say
subscribe here and back in my render
method I say this lock state god sup so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an even handler for that
so here button on click I call another
method and let's call the method button
change okay so this method should update
the state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a stats
tape method now estate can be updated in
respond
to event handlers server responses or
prop changes now all the updation can be
done using the set state method now this
is the general syntax used by the method
we'll have ever look at this further in
the demo now the sex tape method
conventionally enqueues all the updates
me to the component state and instructs
react to rerender the component and its
children with the updated state now
let's go back to our core editor and
look at the working of this method now
here I define the arrow function button
change if you are not familiar with
arrow functions I suggest you read up on
them and this is the general syntax and
here I say this dot set stay inside I
change my message to hit the bell icons
to never miss an update and my sub value
changes to subscribe let's save this and
now if you look at the browser when we
click on the subscribe button the
message changes to hit the bell icon to
never miss an update so moving ahead
let's use a bell icon so that the user
can click on it once he clicks on the
image the image changes and a thank you
message appears on the screen so for
that I have two images I have Bell a and
Bell B so I drag and drop both the
images in my components folder
alright now let's import these images
into our new comm Torchy's file sure I
say import Bell a from Bell a dot PNG
and again I'll say import they'll be
from Bell V dot PNG let me save it to
display the image on the screen we make
use of the image tag now this staff has
two attributes one is the source
attribute that specifies the URL and the
other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component I say I
make use of a paragraph tag that'll help
display the image in the next line and
then I use the image tag now since my
image changes once it's clicked I have
to define a property and pass the event
handler click that will update the image
so here before
defying the source let's go back to our
state and define another property that
is imageurl and let's set it to bail it
since that is the image that I want to
display first and we save it and here in
my image tag as a source equals this dot
state dot image URL and then we have the
alt tag and I do not want to display any
message so I leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bail displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bail
I do not want such a huge bail so back
in my vs code I define style width width
say 30 pixels and a height width again
30 pixels let me save this and now if we
look at the browser we have a smaller
icon so once the user clicks on this
image the image changes and the message
displayed here gets updated to do that
we'll have to define an event so let's
go back to our vs code and here in my
image tag let's say on click and define
a method see this dot image change and
now we define this method here I see
image change and make use of an arrow
function again and again I use the set
State method I update the image so I say
image URL is now set to bell B and the
message is updated to thank you happy
learning so let's save this now and if
we look at the browser we see the image
and once clicked on it the image gets
updated and the message changes so
finally let me refresh the browser once
and show the full execution a me refresh
following the instructions let's click
on the subscribe button and now it says
hit the bell icon and once I do that
they make updates and the message
changes all right so with this we've
come to the end of the video I hope the
concept of state is clear to you water
for more videos on react Cheers until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here